i am changing absolutely nothing think  about it i don't know where the bottom  of the market is going to be so if i say  i'm going to stop buying i have a plan i  buy monthly i buy mutual funds monthly  stocks and bond mutual funds monthly if  i stop and i miss the bottom and stocks  start going up  i lose out on gains  if you look at historical returns if you  miss the top 10 trading days of the year  you miss a huge portion of the gains i  don't know when that bottom is going to  come so i've got to keep buying and then  secondly  i have an asset allocation that i'm  targeting  if i stop buying stocks and bonds  because i'm scared or it might go down  more  well do i go into cash no but it's not  my plan to have more cash so  have the right asset allocation and  stick to the plan is what i'm doing  doesn't mean anybody else should but  that's what i'm doing